[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want we got
new daddy oh [ __ ] not yet not yet
yeah almost oh and then jason's here
jason
zaddy over there daddy and fatty
tell us about the new dad feels dude
yeah tell us when did you come in here
well we've been uh yeah
ago we were she's about she's about
19 18 weeks now yeah 18 weeks so 18 is
about about four four times four
16. yeah almost like five months she's
halfway in she's
halfway in whoa yeah and let me
first of all let me say i was gonna tell
you guys
before the video dropped i really was oh
i was
i was i didn't even care i wasn't even i
wasn't even a part of your friend baby
reveal
well here's the thing i was gonna keep
it just
like petey flow but david's your real
friend
but david to the video here's what
happened see i was gonna keep it my
super tight circle pdf superego ricky
shucks right
and then i just but you know none of
them are going to get your views that's
true so you have to get david in there
what happened was i was i just happened
to be
eating lunch with david and then we were
like let's just tell him
and then i was recording his reaction
for a vlog and i was like
but his reaction was so funny i was like
let me just throw it in we were eating
lunch too
i know well here's the thing i was gonna
tell y'all when you came over with for
the mukbang like i literally was gonna
tell you guys
and but if i would have told you guys
then it would have been before i told
like anybody
so i was like you could have just saved
it for later i get how it works i get
your friend scale i get where i'm at
oh yeah you guys i mean you guys are
like probably like you know um
top 60 no no i'm not y'all are
definitely top 20.
you know i got i got i got like my my my
uh
starting lineup you know who are like my
my my boys
my boys boys cause i don't get the views
the boys who don't get the views
and then i got my but it's not about
views it's about love that's how you
know they're your real friends because
you're not there for their clout
yeah exactly i'm not hanging out with
them for likes but
and then um and then you guys and then
you guys are like my uh you know
second string oh thank you thank you i
appreciate that yeah it's kind of like
we got the jk family and you're like the
extended
yeah family yeah i don't i don't get
invited to a
family vacation nope but you're you can
but i just forget about you yeah and
that's and that's what i was gonna say
and i was gonna tell you all before the
video dropped but i just i literally
just forgot yeah it's okay
i think because i knew my place i was
like oh i get it yeah no hard feelings
like we might invite each other over for
like uh
big things for for like get-togethers
gatherings
yeah but weddings weddings i like to be
treated more like a [ __ ] buddy
than someone coming in because then
there's too
much like there's too much commitment
yeah from
this side you know what to me like i
gotta listen i gotta be there for you
from your side
i have to actually be a friend i like
being treated just for fun
so i love this thing we got going on tim
i'm not hurt
dude yeah i feel the same way
then we got an agreement what's up you
know the
were you one of those people so you know
like back in the day before there's uber
and all that stuff
when you had to and we just do all those
shows together you
would be like oh [ __ ] man who am i gonna
bug at 5am to take me to their youtube
jason like
we all did all shows together right but
then i think for us in our group the
minute that there was
uber we were like okay let's not bug our
friends anymore
and now we can take ourselves places or
even if like someone were to ask me
can you take me to the airport i'm like
i just pay for your uber so i don't have
to wake up at 5am
how are you with that no my dad would
always take me what to all the shows
what like to the air what yeah yeah he
would he would always like
be like before uber right yeah my dad
would always
uh invent it i lived here right i either
lived with them or
you know when i moved out i was only
like a couple blocks away so whenever i
had a show my dad would just drive me to
the airport
and he would always say like we'd be in
traffic and say just get me a motorcycle
i'll get you there so
fast to ride no
you should get involved with the side
car and you sit on that oh my god that
would be your mom
that eliminates the purpose of weaving
through traffic but it looks cute bro
yeah get to the airport either my
girlfriend or i would just
call one of those asian shuttles oh my
mom calls those what is that wait what's
the asian shuttle it's like
a chinese taxi like you literally call
them and they literally make a living
off of picking up people and taking them
to the airport so they're
like a uber but just for chinese people
it's
it's tuber yeah so it's true it's uber
it's uber for chinese people
but because it's chinese you know that
there's a lot more services that they
can provide they pick them in a van
so they come they'll come in a van and
they can go like let's say uh they come
and pick
like us up right it's like a super
shuttle kind of a chinese version and
it's private for us there's gonna be
other strangers on there
so i can go okay after you drop me off
drop her off take tim to get some
mcdonald's
tiff wants to get her hair done and then
just go yes yes yes yes yes
how's that any different from like
getting one of those limousine services
like a car service yeah it's just a car
service
it's like way cheap because it's like 50
are you bucks yeah so we never take
those
cause it's [ __ ] what's i can't even
say this word anymore it's uh
it's expensive it's stupid
it's uh well it's just not what you're
used to it's not american standard
what's the word
it's the new replacement you know what
i'm trying to say right
let me see tell me cut to me when they
tell you
oh uh it is uh yeah just not up to the
american standards like it's just not up
to pogba
it's too poppery you know like prince
and the popper yeah yeah
oh you know what i remember i remember
um korean
um uber guys well they're like just
regular guys
that drove around k-town and they give
you um
oh with their phone numbers on it that
was their business card
and then we would get to raves around
downtown that way
because we would just call them up this
was like in 2002
or whatever like they would just come
pick you up and they
drive like they are drunk and they are
just
fast as hell and they'll smoke like a
pack of cigarettes within like three
minutes
yeah i think i heard that like korea was
one of the first countries to have any
type of like uber
service because people would get so
[ __ ] up they could be the chinese
shuttle though
yeah i guess they copy the shuttle yeah
but those korean dudes they like because
of your parents
age they kind of judge you a little bit
so you're like 2 am still [ __ ]
rolling at you like where you going
you're like oh home what are you doing
out here i'm like what the [ __ ]
he's just looking out for you man what
the [ __ ] you asking all these questions
i'm going to pay you just drop me off
remember when we went to seoul and our
taxi driver was drunk as [ __ ]
she was so scary dude what
he was swerving and i was like [ __ ] i
just want to get to my hotel man
hey can you drive for me he drunk or did
he no he
smelled like alcohol and he was drunk
that's scary and then um
i think i was in the car with uh david
choi and then he was
he was like communicating or whatever
with them and i'm he's like man this
guy's [ __ ]
gone and i'm like oh please i hope we
get to home say
[ __ ] god damn yeah that's crazy
i am i was i almost died
in a car with a drunk driver one time
and it's all because i
wanted some i wanted some ass
i was trying to like hook up with this
girl after a show and um i
literally like almost like we almost
died
and it was like the driver was it so
what man here's what happened here's
what happened all right so it was it was
after a show
me and another rapper homie we um we
like we we
met these two girls after the show and
they're like yeah come come back with us
like alright cool it's lit like we're
gonna we're gonna get it in right
and then so we get to their car but we
didn't know that the car was going to be
filled with
um their drunk friends like it was like
their other group of friends were all
meeting up at the car and they were like
all right let's go
and i'm looking like [ __ ] we're all
about to squeeze into this car and like
this dude's drunk but i was like
whatever i'm trying to smash right so
like i get into this car
literally like we're lapped up she's on
my lap the other girl is on the other
homie's lap the car is packed
this dude's like swerving i'm like [ __ ]
i could have drove
something something but we know we
weren't you know we're this was in
seattle or some [ __ ] yeah
so he's going down the freeway fast oh
jesus and then like let's say like
let's say this is this is the car
driving right and there's one of those
things in the freeway that's like the
big
the lights that's like get over into the
next oh yeah yeah yeah and then
everyone's like yeah everyone's like hey
sean sean there's a thing watch out for
the thing he's like yo chill
chill and like and like literally we
were going so fast
towards this [ __ ] in my head i was like
i'm about to we're about to hit this
[ __ ] i'm gonna use this trick on my lap
so that i don't literally in my head i'm
like all right this [ __ ] is dead
this person's dead uh but i'm like i
might if i brace myself i might be okay
and then like i'm like i'm like okay i'm
bracing myself for it right and
literally at the last minute he went
and like swore around and everyone oh
and he's like i told y'all
oh sorry oh my god in my head i was like
yo i'm never risking my life for some
poon ever again i didn't mean i smashed
and it was great but like it was still
like i'm like never again
the other homie didn't even get the
smash wow the things we do
for just great vagina ah yeah you know
if only she could have just um
came to my hotel because that's more
convenient you know what i'm saying
what happened there um i don't know i
don't know she invited you sir you're
like let's go
if i mean if only there was a service
where you could call somebody and they
could host
some yeah yeah postmates is awesome but
you can't post mates [ __ ]
but what you can post mates is food so
yesterday
i was in the mood for because you know
curry house is closed but i'm like oh
where am i gonna
stop reminding me where's cut where come
am i gonna get some katsu curry so i
found a restaurant local restaurant and
then i post made it
two yummy katsu curries it came with the
little red pickles and everything like
i didn't make coffee them actually
because it has a salad it has the rice
it has a
cotton salad with the corn too yeah and
oh and the corn and it has the uh the
little red pickles and it was so good
thank you postmates that's why i love
using postmates because they deliver
food from every restaurant i can think
of right to my door but post mates
doesn't just deliver burgers and sushi
they actually make my life easier with
grocery delivery and whatever i can
think of delivery too
convenience stores clothing stores you
name it so no more trips to the store no
more late night fast food runs i don't
even have to worry about where to grab
lunch anymore just download post mates
on ios or android
find your favorites and get anything you
want delivered within the hour
for a limited time postmates is giving
our listeners
100 of free delivery credit for your
first
seven days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code off the
record
that's off the record for 100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
wow
for your first seven days when you
download the postmates app anything you
need
anytime you need it post made it it's so
cool though when you have things like
that because
i heard you could even like post make
condoms post me anything oh yeah
we postmated batteries one time
really good i think i told you guys
before but i post made it floss one time
just floss you needed it that bad well i
i have
i need to floss like every night or else
i don't feel like comfortable
you probably have good breath it's it's
pretty good it's pretty good i've been
flossing
lately yeah and one night i was at a
hotel and i'd already showered and got
in like my sleepwear i was like [ __ ] i
don't have floss
so i like postmates they don't really
provide floss
like not all the time and then so and
floss wasn't on the list
for 7-eleven but so i just picked like
toothpaste and i had to write a little
note hey man i don't need toothpaste can
you please give me some floss
and uh just like this one string
he wrapped it on yours what would have
you done if they didn't
have it are you one of those guys that
just can't go to would you start
taking the string out of your shirt
i would have just been i would have i
would have forced myself to sleep but i
would
just woke up feeling hair girls hair
really hair floss yeah when it's like
in your you're just like i have to clean
my [ __ ] mouth so you just do hair
that's emergency sauce on women i just
brush my mouth with my finger
what about it between your teeth and i
go to sleep you have meat stuck in the
middle of your teeth what do you do
i never do because because i don't floss
i have so much tartar
nothing gets in there ever no i don't
get things stuck in between my teeth i
think i have a tight teeth [ __ ]
it's very it's very it's very teeth
[ __ ] that virgin teeth yeah it's not
gappy
but lately i've been flossing because my
friend's uh girlfriend she works at a
dentist's
office and she was sitting where geo was
and she goes
you don't floss do you're not that far
away holy [ __ ] well she's like
she sees teeth all day so she goes you
don't floss do you and i'm like
huh yeah i do she goes how often and i'm
like
uh you know like once a month maybe she
goes lies
she tells it how it is that's why i love
her she's [ __ ] awesome and then
she'll be like
come over and then um we'll hook you up
with the cleaning
i want to feel free she goes yeah
because i do it i'm like all right cool
so i'm gonna start i started flossing
because i got all self-conscious
start no no i i i do it now but then i
laugh and once a month no um i've been
doing it for four days straight now oh
[ __ ] but then before that was like every
other day or when i remember
i only got in the habit because when i
had braces the lady was like
you need to start flossing because the
more i floss the the easier the teeth
will move and then she was like i can
tell you're not flossing if you want to
get your braces off soon and you should
floss like oh okay so i got in the habit
and then i just kind of like
i need to do it now because i got a
tooth over here it's like i swear man
i don't know what's wrong with this
tooth over here but i'll be like it's
like it's like chunks of like food will
come out if when i floss that
you guys get cavities easy back here too
toothpicks
oh it's too picky that's sure i'll use a
toothpick right now oh
i flossed last today but those plastic
toothpicks
no it's weird like every tooth right
it's usually just what's the
uncomfortable but floss you're supposed
to do
every single one yeah get in there
you guys use tongue scrapers i just
started using a tongue scraper i use my
toothbrush
yeah i just use my two plus two bow get
a [ __ ] tongue scraper dog
that shit's crazy once you start using
those and you
you do it and you see all the film come
off your tongue
it's like layers bro it's gross
yeah one time the first time i got it
because i have a metal one
so the first time i got it i was like
tongue scraping the [ __ ] out of it where
i
like actually hurt my tongue oh god
because i was so fascinated with all the
[ __ ] that was coming off i was like what
the [ __ ]
why don't you just use your toothbrush
and go ah that's what i do
nah it does more and it's just funny
because you get a peeler like a potato
peeler oh yeah
might as well cheese grater that's too
rough
i hurt myself too first time i used my
tongue because i was i was also
so into it i think i extended my jaw too
wide
and then like then like for the next
like two weeks my like my [ __ ] hurt i
went to a chiropractor and everything
just kind of like no right now i'm
currently dealing with that stuff my
jaw's out of line
it hurts i've been oh damn casey okay
okay
what was that that's a man's blow job i
i thought
lots of teeth yeah i like the cinnamon
toothpicks
two toothpicks oh those are flavored
really good no i pretend that they do
like and i like the one he's like that
is lemon toothpaste health
do you remember when supreme was selling
toothpicks no what
seriously yeah how much was it like a
million dollars bro i don't remember
exactly how much but they put out a pack
of two picks and it was like
a brick too true aren't they like
the bit the best trolls where the joke
actually became serious
that's crazy and it's a billion dollar
company a billion
yeah they're a billion dollar company
isn't that crazy
toothpicks yeah wait is does this take
you three million
tea tree oil toothpicks does it say
supreme on them well it's just a box
wait what does it say on the toothpick
though on the top part
it's a regular regular japanese one it's
just it's just a box this is yeah that's
it they're just selling it's just the
hype you know how do they just make
whatever
they just make whatever branding yeah
they killed it insane
and then it kind of became a thing where
it's like yeah yeah it's funny that it's
so expensive but then it's like but [ __ ]
if you have it it's like oh
[ __ ] okay baller it's like you paid all
that money to to be funny just to have
it yeah
our neighbor was telling because like
our neighbor's pretty balling and he was
showing us his garage and he's got like
all these nba [ __ ] shoes all
autographed and [ __ ] and he's probably
like it
and then he goes check this [ __ ] out and
then he shows us his toolbox and it's
just supreme he's like i'm so dumb i
paid 20 grand for this
what so just to put in perspective i
have a i bought it like a regular
toolbox you like the kind that has
wheels and you have like
uh drawers i paid 500 bucks for that for
him he bought the same exact one but
because it was supremo's 20 g's he's
like i'm so stupid a toolbox
a toolbox 20 000 for a toolbox i bet you
it's probably like
a regular toolbox that they just put
their logo probably it looks like it
he could probably sell it for 40 grand
though
the reason why he buys it he says it is
stupid but the minute he bought it he
already know he made money
yeah you don't make money unless you
sell it though
that's true well how does it work like
is it limited is that why the value's so
high and then they release it
and then you can get it like from them
and then you just hold on to it and
other people are like
i'll buy it everything is limited i
don't think they i don't think they
re-release like anything really to be
honest i got this like regular ass
i mean it's my favorite shirt it's like
a it's like a light blue flannel with a
hood that i wear all the time
and people are always like yo would you
get that flannel like oh it's a spring
one bro they're like oh [ __ ] because
they know they're not gonna be able to
like find it anywhere you know
what's limited to them like a thousand
like how many they release i don't know
but if you if you pass by the supreme
story on libreo there's always whenever
they have their new drop there's always
like a line outside
wow because someone can't wait to get
the
little what the red wagon from supreme
or something right they want to get
there
like i can't wait i've been waiting
paid 40 g's for this their baby got
supreme shoes on and [ __ ]
oh my god i want to do something like
that
where we just make something like
puprem or some [ __ ] and it's a it's a
kazoo and i'ma release five
and each of these cost ten thousand
dollars
i'm not mad because they did that as a
joke and then people are buying that
[ __ ] now
are they in there with the joke or are
they actually flossing it like it's
louis vuitton
or whatever you know i think anybody who
who buys
that like poo preem like kazoo
is like buying it because it's gonna be
collector's item you know what i'm
saying they're not at parties like
blowing it
yeah i didn't see no tools in my
neighbor's toolbox
i think he still had a regular toolbox
and he put his tools in it is aside from
like
all right so the whole point of that
company was to
laugh at bragging rights right and then
they made it but
it kind of backfired and it worked it
was fire in a good way high culture
high culture it's yeah hype culture i
don't even understand it like do you
understand how
how they became so big or how so
valuable
nah i don't know i have no idea because
everyone else tries to be them but
there's
really no other company that maybe
besides
jordan's that you buy something and it's
literally worth double the next day
rolex but it's still not double oh it
holds its value but it's not double some
of them
get at daytona it's like a double oh
that's true and plus like i doubt if
rolex put out toothpicks they would like
people would care
yeah they put out anything they put out
anything
it's like literally all about that name
and that logo yeah like a [ __ ]
toolbox i don't know supreme was into
tools and [ __ ]
through the skateboards yeah if they
came up with so much
toilet paper i wouldn't be surprised you
probably have i think they have bruh
see google it okay google it right now
they came out with the battering ram too
before i think
really like the like the thing that like
swat teams used to bust down doors it's
like a little like
it was like this big came out with one
of those guys they could come out with
home depot items
and they'll still bomb they did [ __ ]
toolbox
toolbox a brick i don't know if they
have a power drill
because i see some but they look like
like photoshop [ __ ] yeah
i don't think they've gone into food yet
though
supreme burger oh [ __ ] save it forever
like a thousand dollars
yeah a supreme restaurant can you
imagine that
we're only serving two burgers for one
week
yeah supreme water oh yeah
we're only giving three out and we're
going to do it at the mojave desert
we even have a tissue holder thingy okay
that's kind of cool
that's kind of cool i like their it's
all red and white though i like red and
white
it is pretty clean though real though i
don't know who knows
it's like a china knockoff who knows
you